bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 7 8
l'aktu de ce vendredi 21 mars vous le
savez comme tous les jours nous allons
faire le point sur votre actualité
locale
tout d'abord le dossier akka
technologies continuent après leur
mouvement du des 14 et 28 février
dernier et surtout le silence de la
direction les salariés de l'entreprise
s'apprête à nouveau à manifester ce
vendredi devant le siège social de la
firme à boulogne-billancourt
les employés basés notamment à
guyancourt protestent toujours contre la
politique de l'entreprise de modifier le
barème de remboursement de frais ils
perdent en moyenne entre 300 et 900
euros par mois selon les cas à noter
qu'à quatre technologies a fait état
d'un chiffre d'affaires de 231 millions
d'euros au quatrième trimestre 2013
en repli de 1,6 pour cent mais le groupe
a légèrement dépassé son objectif annuel
de 875 millions d'euros négocié leur
appareil qui soit vraiment comment
dirais je a vraiment un testament du
salarié l'idea si vous voulez pour nous
la salle il va sacrer offert est
aujourd'hui puisque l'argumentation la
direction aujourd'hui sega va se mettre
en conformité avec nos âmes et si vous
les urssaf figurent la société m 150
euros aujourd'hui à salariés si le
salarié justifie les 150 euros pour les
salariés aucun problème puisque justifie
nouveau dit si vraiment c'est de se
mettre en conformité de l'amf entend pas
sourde aux frères est ce simplement tout
ça pour la société parce qu'aujourd'hui
en fin de compte soit dans le nouveau
barème c'est vraiment une mesure
d'économie
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines semble sauvée
du moins à court terme l'état a annoncé
il ya quelques jours qu'il verserait une
avance remboursable de 2,6 millions
d'euros en décembre dernier le ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur avait déjà
dû verser 800 mille euros cette annonce
est tombée en même temps que le rapport
de la cour des comptes qui couvre la
période 2006 2012 et reprend des
critiques déjà émise lors de la
découverte du déficit du budget de l'ue
vs qu par exemple des opérations de
partenariat public-privé mal géré un
recours excessif aux heures
supplémentaires ou encore une
augmentation mal maîtrisée des emplois
les lycéens avaient jusqu'à mercredi
pour compléter leur souhait post-bac les
questions sont souvent nombreuses
concernant la bonne orientation à
prendre dans les années futures des
réponses que peuvent apporter les
conseillers d'orientation psychologues
et des sociétés de coaching privé
souhaite aussi de rentrer dans ce
créneau exemple à versailles sabrina
sikinis l'orientation une formalité pour
les uns en casse-tête pour les autres
sonia tahar haddad l'a bien compris il y
a un an cet ancien salarié de saint
gobain titulaire d'un capes d'espagnol
s'est lancé dans le coaching dans
l'intention privé on oriente les élèves
depuis la classe de 3e jusqu'à jusqu'aux
études supérieures l'avantagent
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on permette aux
élèves d'accéder à beaucoup de domaines
d'études quelle que soit leur filière de
formation
la seule chose c'est qu'on leur dit pas
comment y accéder correctement vous le
ou le plus simplement possible pour
certains son bac en poche
camille décide d'étudier la médiation
culturelle trois ans plus tard elle se
rend compte qu'elle s'est trompée elle
frappe alors à la porte du coach on est
quand je suis allé pour ce que j'avais
un coup de coeur et c'est une formation
qui je pense est pouvait me convenir
mais en fait on n'a pas épuisé
dans mes champs la jeune femme souhaite
désormais s'orienter vers des études de
graphisme
lors des entretiens avec sa conseillère
elle a été déroutée par le nombre de
formations possibles
alyssa elle est en terminale
scientifique
il y a un an elle a des doutes quant à
son avenir professionnel
lors des séances de coaching elle
confirme son appétence pour le commerce
aujourd'hui sonia tarradas compagne
alice a dans l'enregistrement de ses
voeux sur le site admission post bac
avec de gros si certaines familles
trouvent leur compte
les conseillers d'orientation
psychologues émettre quelques réserves
quant au développement du coaching privé
en ligne de mire la formation des
coaches je peux poser la question de la
formation des coaches n'importe qui
ayant fait n'importe quelles études
avant de se nommer france
le problème c'est que tout jeune ne peut
pas s'offrir les services coaching
figuré pour l'orientation ici à
versailles
les tarifs du coaching varie entre 330
et 580 euros pour 4 heures d'entretien
des sommes que certains sont prêts à
payer pour être rassurés sur leur choix
le solar decathlon de versailles a
annoncé le parrain de son l'édition 2014
il s'agit du navigateur vainqueur du
vendée globe michel desjoyeaux amarin
depuis longtemps concerné 1 par le
devenir de la planète
olivier maniscalco et jonathan wilmet
vous allez me dire le parallèle entre
les bateaux allaient ils solar decathlon
en fait sur un bateau à voile a fortiori
en compétition les très économe en
énergie
michel desjoyeaux parrain du solar
decathlon europe de versailles c'est
lors d'un point presse le 17 mars au
ministère de l'égalité des territoires
et du logement que l'annoncé a été
officialisée compétition internationale
d'architecturé environnementale
le solar elle ira en juillet prochain le
meilleur projet étudiant de maisons
alimenter en énergie solaire
le navigateur finistériens double
vainqueur du vendée globe a tout de
suite adhéré au projet et apportera
outre sa notoriété une conscience
écologique qui ne date pas d'hier
moi j'ai tout de suite embrayé sur la
proposition à titre perso tout
simplement parce que je suis passionné
de technologies d'innovation de
compétition aussi mais je suis aussi
tout simplement citoyen mais deux
dernières maisons sont équipées de
panneaux solaires thermiques même en
bretagne a su assez de soleil pour
chauffer de l'eau
et sur la prochaine dont j'ai déposé le
permis de construire récemment j'ai bien
l'intention de mettre du solaire
thermique du solaire photovoltaïque de
l'éolien de la récupération d'eau de
pluie pour la première fois organisé en
france la compétition accueillera du 16
juin au 19 juillet les projets de 20
nationalités différentes des projets qui
seront exposées au grand public durant
18 jours près du château de versailles
le solar va ainsi permettre un coup de
projecteur sur la maison écologique du
futur c'est le moyen de montrer qu'on
peut construire différemment qu'on peut
améliorer des bâtiments existants et
qu'on peut faire beaucoup d'économies
d'énergie et utiliser les énergies
renouvelables dans le bâtiment
et puis de montrer aussi toutes les
inventions toutes les innovations qui
sont en cours dans ce secteur
c'est une bonne manière de montrer
effectivement qu'on est plus seulement
dans l'innovation innovation en train de
de découler dans nos réalisations
concrètes et c'est nécessaire parce que
la transition énergétique
c'est vraiment le challenge du 21e
siècle de notre continent et donc de
notre pays
lors de ce solar decathlon europe deux
projets français seront présentés en
2012 lors de la dernière édition c'est
un prototype grenoblois qu'il l'avait
emporté si vous possédez votre carte
d'électeur vous le savez vous êtes
appelés aux urnes ce dimanche 23 mars
pour le premier tour des élections
municipales vous voterez donc pour vos
conseillers municipaux comme d'habitude
mais nouveauté cette année également
pour vos conseillers communautaires mode
d'emploi avec catherine m'vila tôt
du nouveau pour les électeurs lors de
ces élections municipales dont le
premier tour se déroule le 23 mars
ils voteront bien évidemment pour une
liste vos conseillers municipaux mais
également pour choisir ceux qui
siègeront au sein des agglomérations
les conseillers communautaires étaient
auparavant élus par leurs pairs ils le
seront maintenant au suffrage universel
direct
en conséquence dimanche les électeurs
verront apparaître sur un même et seul
butin au format paysage deux listes une
liste de conseillers municipaux et une
liste de conseillers communautaires
les listes ne pourront pas être séparés
et vous ne pourrez pas rayer de nom par
exemple à montigny le bretonneux
les électeurs auront le choix entre
trois listes de candidats chaque liste
comprendra trente neuf noms de
conseillers municipaux et parmi ces 39
non treize ont été choisis pour être
proposé comme conseiller communautaire
ces deux listes seront paritaire un
homme une femme un homme une femme et
c'est à 50 ans ni vis ni lee a donc 48
conseillers communautaires à élire
répartis en fonction de la taille
démographique des villes
un nouveau scrutin qui changent bien la
donne car le nombre de conseillers
communautaires siégeant par commune à
l'agglomération dépendra demain du
résultat réalisé par chaque liste c'est
le principe du scrutin proportionnel
dans les yvelines pour ces élections il
y à 5310 conseillers municipaux à élire
et 737 conseillers communautaires au
suffrage universel direct
il ya quinze jours cet homme est entré
dans la légende du cyclisme sur piste le
nouvel unis montrent un françois pervis
a décroché trois titres de champion du
monde rien que ça en keirin sur le
kilomètre et sur la vitesse individuelle
il signe là un triplé historique et
inédit jamais personne n'avait réalisé
une telle performance dans un même
championnat du monde
de retour de colombie françois pervis
nous a accordé une interview vérité et
est revenu sur son exploit premier david
orr c'est un trip est unique puisque je
suis premier demi soeur de mon sport a
gagné les trois épreuves individuelles
ont que j'avais annoncé avant de partir
c'était mon objectif
j'ai réussi à le faire et ça n'a pas été
une chose simple forcément c
forcément je suis super content et vous
pourrez retrouver évidemment
l'intégralité de cet entretien dans le
prochain 7,8 sports lundi à 18h30
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
encore une fois de l'avoir suivi pour
toutes vos idées de sorties vous
retrouver la charmante héroïne torres
pour le 7-8 week-end quant à moi je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de journée
sur tv fille